when we are driving around in the middle
of night
you will see a homeless person sleeping
somewhere
and you just think what can i do for
them most of us will be relieved to see
the end of 2020
not more so than healthcare
professionals like dr zaheed chohan
as a gp in oldham and a local councillor
with responsibility for health and
social care
he hasn't had a day off since the early
days of the pandemic
it's a year that's brought him
professional pride and personal sadness
it's a feeling of joy and honor that you
you've been there
and you played your role in in as
a as a health care leader you made a
difference in people's life
and somehow somewhere regret as well
whether you neglected your family
during all that time from a virtual
standing start dr chohan and his
colleagues have had to learn quickly
and adapt to new ways of working yes
it's been scary thinking oh am i going
to contract it or am i likely to pass
this on to
my dad who's elderly or things like that
but i've just had to change the way i've
done things be more careful the arrival
of vaccines should provide a route back
to normality
but there's still a fear that the mental
health issues created by the pandemic
could be the next crisis the country has
to face your blood pressure is
absolutely fine
a crisis that once again will affect
both the public
and the healthcare workers trying to
protect them
i was working during the day in the
afternoon
was burying my colleague putting him in
grave in my own hands the person i've
been working with for a very long time
then you go home wash up and you see
your children
you see your wife and and you're trying
to sleep
and what impact that will have on you
of course it will impact on your mental
health there's not been a coordinated
structured national approach to this at
all
and these staff have been working
absolutely non-stop
since the beginning of our first surge
so staffer
exhausted both physically and mentally
the year may be nearing its close but
the work of frontline health and care
workers like dr chohan will continue
regardless
his new year wish better resources for
the nhs and for social care
along with a comprehensive review to
identify where we went wrong
in handling a pandemic which has ruined
so many lives
fraser moored sky news